oh
so close actually there's another
tournament coming up
i said i was going to do back to back
and let's go this is already starting
vip warzone
entered
let's roll here
facebook is a good way to connect i've
posted that link
in the um
in the chat so let's do this oh man that
was like that was such a tease right
there
i was like oh you have the chance to win
you're up a point and then you get
a beating right there you get hit with
the what
oh why am i playing so quick against
this guy here
okay wait i have something against h7
h7 is on
let's back up here bishop c5 stuff could
be annoying
it's gonna be a knight right there hang
on
let's get this out
and then my light square bishop wants to
be where
somewhere
somewhere it wants to be come on you can
get this tournament can you
uh why did they do that
i'm getting the queen now
i have this defended h7 whoa they're
going for this imbalance i'm getting
ready to take that bishop out
you need to go bishop
help my queen out i don't want to give
up this file just yet
um
and keep my queen active
and look for mate next
okay now the this is broken down here
maintenance ii
right here
real close to me
the rook has to go somewhere here i
think like to this square
but there's check check me back to
tournament five
two
two somebody has this is the guy that
has five
oh man
why did i capture okay so this is an
exchange caro khan
and
okay i think i want to just take that
knight out
or maybe not
yeah no no no no i'm gonna do this
actually take my bishop double my pawns
allow me to get to e4
okay let me let me just do this and i'm
gonna support my knight when it's
challenged with knight to d2
looking for a good versus bad bishop
type of position and i think we're close
to getting that right now
okay let's play over on this side of the
board my knight covers g5 an important
detail and i'm just going to take here
let's go i want to keep this structure
let's go
actually my knight on c4 maybe now let's
do this
open this queen side up
and i want to get my knight to c4 now
knight c4 this is going to come under
some heavy fire let's support it
and i'm going to go with my rook get one
piece off and then
what's the clock situation this guy's in
the lead i can't lose this game
i'm on the bishop bishop right here is
coming into play
it's a bit scary
and uh
they're really scary actually okay queen
trade just oh there's gonna be rook
takes pawn but i get the queens off i
want the queens to come off
just let the queens come off i'm on the
rook hopefully this is working out and i
have a good position because i have a
better structure
i'm on the rook
hang on
get my rook active okay i need to get
this on
can i get that pawn
it's going to be a pawn push i get my
king in position now and the rook right
behind it
right here i can't do this push just yet
because it's my knight is pinned i just
said i can't do that push why did i do
that okay i get this guy at least
why'd i do that i just ah man
move confusion grab puns
it's gonna be undermined though
oh
it's scary over here and i don't okay
this is all right i think
get this pawn
get my knight back to a good position
oh no i gotta throw in pre-moves
pre-move pre-move
right here i gotta be i gotta use my
tricky night tricky night tricky night i
should have given a check tricky night
what do we got what's the clock count
back to tournaments or down on time
oh six six five three
oh man
i was holding my breath again on that
one
david blaine
i turn into david blaine sometimes and
just have fun holding my breath
i don't know why i do it but i do it
okay d3 when it gets intense
let's go f5 knight f5 you know you want
to go there my mouse is being bad to me
he's a bad mouse
he's a bad mouse take that knight no
don't take the knight because he's
pinned and a pinned piece is a powerless
one now we're gonna take and now we're
gonna chop and if you take back i got
mate in two one two actually there's a
three the knight could block that's it
12 6 5 3.
let's roll here
24
minutes
remaining
here we go
oh this guy did i play this guy already
what is this what do we call this the
ponziani or something
anyhow let's get developed here
and actually let me take into account
that uh c4 move so let's not be so quick
to
hang on let's do this let's do that
let's go here get my light square bishop
out okay it's not going to be so easy
cannot be easy can it my queen is
getting chased away
watch out night my queen has to run into
a hole
i think on v8 soon let's get here oh
there's going to be night move here this
is going to be trouble i'm going to try
it though
it's trouble but i'm going to try it
a ugly pond to have to stare at right
here don't
don't look at that oh this is bad i'm
dropping material
where am i
um this is scary oh boy
oh
boy hopefully this is working it's not
working though
oh it's not working what do i have
oh man i don't have anything good just
move oh this is bad this is bad this is
bad i'm getting forked and everything
i gotta give up my queen or is this a
save is this a save somehow
is this a save it might be a save
uh oh it might be a save no it's not
okay i just dropped the exchange and a
knight
they're pretty maybe gonna pre-move that
one
i was being sneaky with that let's take
this guy and then flight square
i need to get my queen off of this back
rank
take this guy oh this is bad news this
is bad news
wherever i look it's bad news here oh
the queens are off
anything but that one
take the pun
i'm a dead man i'm a dead man
kill the knight can i actually get this
they're just pre-moving are they going
to take this
are they going to take my pawn can i
save a draw i gotta draw oh i'll take it
oh 12 12.
oh better than a loss oh i spent so much
time trying to
weasel out of forks and there was a fork
it was inevitable
that night was brutal
oh a brutal knight on a d5 i could not
tolerate that guy
he was just bad news everything about
that knight said bad news
i should play d4
right now
and uh i'm gonna take that knight
and then take here and i'm getting
whoa i didn't expect that one
i gotta watch out because there's queen
checks oh i'm a dead man again pawn
takes there's a queen check on b6
oh there goes the bishop i know no i
have a block actually
okay i think maybe switching the move
order would have been good all right i
think i'm back to her right
now let's go oh my bishop's dead holy
smokes okay i have to get up the
exchange now
oh there goes the exchange
and i have a pretty bishop though he's
sitting proud right there in the center
sitting proud bishop
um
and they're running out of time let's
watch out for that b5 break
and i think i want to tuck my king away
not there
mouse lips
mouse slips everywhere grab this pawn
maybe
can you give me that pawn i'll take him
and then get to f7
oh
f7 is under fire
f7 is defended
watch out for the mates
i'm okay with the queen trade actually
pawn push is a good idea i think they're
okay well
let's push this guy i guess
okay i'm on f7 still
they can't win this there's no time to
win it right
less than five less than 20 minutes in
the tournament just do that
come here no time anything
anything back to tournament 2020.
who is this guy sicilian
some sicilian guy
here we go less than 20
oh
man these are
tight here
let's see is this going to be fired up
or what
oh let's go here
why isn't this starting is there
something wrong let me run a test
test
okay it works
it's working
um
let's go why am i not getting paired up
these are precious seconds am i getting
hit with the comcast gambit
no that can't be the case because
because that test
uh
why am i look at this the clock is
ticking i'm not getting paired up what's
happening
oh okay finally
paired up now okay
oh small pawn center how many mouth
slips can you have
uh oh take the knight take the knight
take the knight i'm on the rook and mate
they're not falling for it
nope let's guard this knight my light
square bishop wants to play
one day
take em
light square weaknesses come on bishop
get castled
queenside castle let's actually do this
take my knight and give the light square
bishop up
you gotta go i cannot deal with you
no way
i'm gonna queenside castle i'm dropping
a pawn but i want to get that h file
opened up
this pawn
and
let's open this up
maybe crunch the bishop here it's
crunched he's got to go back home
i don't know why i did that
um
yeah okay wait okay maybe there is
something i'm going to take on h7
and then play h4
open this uh
position up here
discover checks could take this twice i
got checks on h2 now checks on h2 i'm
connected the bishop is uh
is what
can you take that bishop it's made or
something
it's probably not mate but
make them think
make them think check
just play here it seems right
even though it's it's wrong here oh it's
so wrong
okay i need to time time burn
time burn is the plan
oh
because i don't have anything here let's
trade
come on queen trade they don't have any
time hang on to a rook you need to hang
onto a rook
let's go
here
and then here
take
defend something
run over here no they would take it
oh i got this let's come back how much
time oh i don't have any time time
burners time burners we're the time
burners
ah
come on anything anything just move take
this pawn give a check yes donna they're
down on time oh that was a bit reckless
right there at the end
okay
i was relying on the clock when i was
making some of my moves here we go this
guy's in the lead this is the pack
leader right here
okay we're gonna go for this
all right i'm gonna go after that pawn
where am i
all right well this is this is a good um
it's not so easy to exploit
and let me double up they want to draw i
don't want to draw
let's back up my knight wants to be
somewhere else
and that somewhere else is right here
and you've gone far enough pawn or have
you let me do this actually
and bump up my king
and then there's going to be a pawn push
i got to support my bishop i guess my
knight wants to do something else
oh
oh man
my bishop's dead i want to get to c1
it's coordinated when it's on c1 okay
now i don't know what there is
over here what is my knight doing he's
stupid stupid knight
let's keep a close pawn push i could
take a couple times can i
okay it's closed and now the action is
going to turn to the d file let's go d
file both pawns this is good
grab a pawn give a fork wear the forks
looking for forks
okay i want to get in uh f4 next i have
a majority over here kick that king away
get out of there king watch out for the
tricky night
let's come back here coordinate
coordinate
what am i doing with that move i don't
even know i don't have answers to these
questions that i'm throwing out there
ah
okay i don't even know what that's doing
either
what am i doing
get these guys going here okay clock
situation is still decent
king c3 king improvement
i gotta trade i guess no i want to keep
a rook on the board they might take my
knight
ah look out for the forks forks
everywhere
give a check and then get the rook okay
this is good
finally the smoke is cleared that was a
big win he was the leader of the pack
42-39
he hit a speed bump
i needed to be a speed bump in that one
nap three again this is the guy that
should have beat me when i was uh
killing uh
i was giving away all that material
right there
um
what next okay queen
to c7 pawn push
in the chop
bishop d6
is on the agenda
uh oh
coming up
i wonder if my opponent is just always
like oh he's going for that again i've
done this so many times against this
this opponent here nap
it's probably having like
i don't know
how how does he feel about that
because it never works it never works
let's go open it up is that pointing to
me taken maybe
they're trying to do that against me my
knight is there let's get out of there
queen
let's take this guy
because i could he's free
and then my knight can't be deflected
away or could it the bishop could take
the pawn here
um
ah what am i doing just come back here
defend that pawn
uh time situation is very tight here
okay i gotta come over here
and i gotta come over here
okay let's hang on to that pawn here and
finally get some stuff going here okay
let's do this and take my bishop it's
okay
just take them
let's just trade here can we trade
i just want to trade and let everything
be nice and cozy
just take him
oh now it could be taken
oh there's forks and everything
trades
checks
why'd i do that i'm dropping stuff
that pawn is falling
oh everything's falling
why'd i go with this variation do they
have no time again is the night going to
be trapped it's trapped as a trapped
night is it trapped night oh just in the
nick of time a trapped knight
oh man
king position where's the king position
hang on
why am i not trying to win this in the
right way let's go here
and then here and then here
and then here
get the pawn up
pawn up
okay they're down on time
again barely 69 64 56 where did my lead
go
went down the tubes
ah
let's go here
11 minutes and change
again this guy this is the pack leader
again i'm having to
play this guy
okay we're having an open sicilian this
is the zveznikov i finally was able to
remember that
bishop d3
castle night out
king in the corner f4
and then what
and then maybe g4
i don't know
let's preserve my knight's position
i'm gonna take this guy out here and now
queen over where okay we're having this
back up defend that pawn and then queen
to g3
might be an exchange sack coming up
or that
i gotta open this up here
kill the knight is the plan i'm on e6
pressure on e6 this is a soft point
uh oh
uh oh
let me take where
no i don't know what i'm doing okay no
no no no no they can't let me go here
um there there wasn't pawn takes towards
the center
i'm on the night i'm on the rook
pieces are getting hit
uh i'm on the queen the knight can't
move
i'm on the rook i could have taken the
rook i could have taken the rook and now
i can't but i have this
right here no that's not working
or is it
it's not it's not working no it is
working i'm on the queen oh
i almost missed that i almost missed
that i was on the queen
72-67
might i be playing against that guy
again
this person again um
happy sad
i'm playing against happy sad here
okay man
this is intense
uh knight c6
bishop to e2 this is the same variation
i played
before and i can't develop my bishop
otherwise knight c3 and then there's a
an avalanche of pawns coming at me um
this is this the guy that i played
against and i i was lucky to even draw
i think it was i think there was that
knight d5
that came into play or i think early in
that game a3 was played let me take that
bishop
a3 was played to stop the night pivot
now i have the bishop pair and control
over d5 which is uh
very important
blockade
that isolated pawn is the plan recapture
the queen threaten mate
my rooks will then be connected rook
takes rook is no good let's get rid of
that knight you need to go knight
and
i got that bishop
right
there is no knight move here or here to
save the bishop
this isn't saving it either same thing
with now my rook being on uh
an open file that just helped me out
actually
what's the scoop resignation
12 seconds
eight minutes left in the tournament
less than
five four three two one
let's go here
okay
and i got the rook
okay back to tournament 90 85 81
still very tight anybody's game
eight minutes
exactly remaining
um
let's go here
what is going on there are
it's pretty top heavy right here
22
22 22 21 21
um
let's go i got 10 games in this guy has
13.
they are not pairing me up let me jump
into a game that's going on
come on
white oh white is down on time and
position down the exchange i'm not
getting paired up quick okay i am
getting paired up now
hack comic
double points play e4 look for the quick
wins where are the quick wins
fantasy
bishop d3
oh no no no no knight c3 bishop d3
uh okay i have to take with my pawn let
me do this i'm dropping this in some
variations but maybe it's okay
okay let's guard it now queen e1 to h4
with e5 to play
they're defending that okay i have
bishop takes h6 i'm going to take with
my pawn i think now i'm on this making
one threat
got the rook
i want this f file the f7 point get the
knight out of there
oh it's a little scary there's gonna be
bishop check and stuff
it should be played
it's not played uh-oh
more material what do we have what is
the scoop i want to play here
e5 if it's
okay let's come over here e5 for so many
reasons
this square the bishop wants to see the
game
f6 is a weak point
let's go
knight f6 could be a pre-move
okay they resigned back to tournament
leaders where we at 110 105 101 still
too tight either one of those guys could
win in a second and beat me
i want to get that first blaze
it's all about the first place confetti
let's go here who's this another tough
cookie
who is this
c5 and
oh it's my move that is not a good sign
already
it's my move here let's go
um
a6 queen c7
look for the killer mates knight to g4
let's go knight g4 you know you want to
be there
mate on h2 is it going to be defended
take the knight he's free
bishop here
watch out for the mates i'm going to
back my bishop up
if knight b3 i want to stay on this
diagonal this knight cannot be captured
it's bad news if the night is captured
let's try this it's scary but i'm going
to do it
because there's a bishop check my king's
going to run for the hills
run oh
i didn't see that one
did they see that one
probably they're in a pin
and
i'm having to still develop this is very
awkward
okay i guess that guy has to go and i
want to get castled and still not
castled
oh this is bad
right here i guess
and
oh this is very scary i didn't this is
not happening
oh there goes my queen
oh there goes everything i'm getting
checked around real bad here don't you
dare give a check
take the pawn take him take him it's me
oh it would have been made if they took
it
do i have this somehow i'm on the bishop
no i don't
oh this is bad news where's the forks
where are the forks when you need it
where are the forks give me a fork
i need forks and they're nowhere to be
found there's checks and everything oh
there's nothing here
i can't win this
tricky night
oh i better hit the resign button
hit the resign button go cry in a corner
oh
there's no hope now
161 135
ah did i take a beating
that was stupid to play f5 don't you
dare do that again
shame on you you deserve to lose
you deserve to lose that's what you get
for being ambitious with that f5 move
you were being way too reckless
you deserve to lose that one
you have nobody to blame but yourself
let's just trade can we trade a little
bit so things are nice and cozy
where are the cozy positions
okay here's a cozy one it's trade end
game the king does not move like that
let's roll here
i don't want a knight to sit here
no knights allowed on f4 or bishops now
okay i have a majority four to three on
this side of the board let's go apon
let's go apon
and let's go knight you want to be on d3
it's a good square you're going to love
it
and then we're going to get pieces
rolling here actually let's go here this
is a weakness maybe i'm going to get at
that guy and then my apon's pounds gonna
be excited about scoring a touchdown
maybe
get out of there bishop
uh oh
uh oh who's in a pin now
let's go
take a rook
and then let's get this in is this
somehow working
no it's not
why i do that
okay what's the time situation
is it okay
let's try this there might be something
to it
or not
oh wait yeah maybe still the bishop
can't attack my knight
let's keep that closed don't try to open
that up i have to win this one
oh i'm dropping a pawn but this is a
pass pawn but they have a pass pun
oh i'm a dead man
oh
no they could take my knight a couple
times they didn't take it
save the day night
take a palm will never suspect that one
or yes they will they don't have time to
hold back to turn
one minute 39 i'm not gonna get top
three there's not going to be any
confetti in sight if you're waiting
around for confetti
uh
you're you're wasting your time it's not
happening
oh
man
that took the wind out of me did you
realize that did you hear it in my voice
after i realized that confetti is not
possible
after i realized it's out the window
it took the wind right out of me
top three is way off wait a second
though the h-pawn has something to say
about it
let's go pun
let's do that i guess
come on open up the h file
and go for win
kill the king where's the mate
trade
bishops hit the rook i'm on this pond
i'm on the queen i'm on the bishop i'm
on the queen i'm on the bishop i'm on
both bishops i'm on everything
take pieces they're free
there's so many free pieces here ah just
take some of them i'm on the rook
hmm where's the mate i'm dropping a pond
they're dropping a rook though there's
dropping a rook resign resign resign
i can't get confetti though
oh come on
discover tricks
discover check
oh thanks for playing
oh i got hit with uh
the well done in a pat on the back
ah thanks for playing
nobody wants to see that
nobody wants to just see it thanks for
playing i wanted a little
trophy with the
little sheen to it there's no sheen look
at this guy has 19 games in
look at these guys they're animals 191
178 153
19 17 18 13
16
everybody has more games in than me i
had a loss in a
draw
which should have been two losses
ah
brutal